here's what would happen if you had a  butterfly infestation at first you'd  have a small wound that you might think  looks like a pimple or a cyst but over  time it would become inflamed making you  itch like crazy  this is a parasite eating you from the  inside and because it's so active at  night the unbearable discomfort would  prevent you from sleeping  the wound would get larger growing along  with the baby bot fly as time goes on  if you left the wound untreated you'd be  experiencing stabbing pains for up to 10  weeks  things would get even worse if the larva  died while inside you or if the body was  yanked out fast or smashed the pieces  left inside could create an infection  that would spread if you didn't treat it  if the butterfly larva grew into a pupa  it would eventually find its way out of  your body on its own  it wouldn't kill you but